cuánto es siete centenas por diez vamos
a enfocarnos primero en esta parte que
dice x 10 ya que multiplicar por 10
tiene cierto patrón en matemáticas que
podemos usar para resolver esto un
patrón que podemos pensar al multiplicar
por 10 es si tenemos un número entero y
lo multiplicamos por 10 simplemente
vamos a agregar un 0 al final de este
número por ejemplo si tenemos un número
entero como 9 y lo multiplicamos por 10
nuestra solución será un 9 con un 0 al
final o 90 ya que 9 por 10
es lo mismo que 9 decenas y 9 decenas es
90 así que primero vamos a usar este
patrón tenemos 7 centenas así que
tenemos siete veces 100 o 700 que
multiplicamos por 10 usamos este patrón
de aquí por lo que nuestra solución
tendrá un 0 al final si tenemos 710
veces tendremos 700 con un 0 al final
por lo que 700 por 10 es 7000
pero hay otro patrón que podemos usar y
este otro patrón es que cuando
multiplicamos por 10 vamos a mover cada
dígito una posición de valor a la
izquierda oa una posición de valor mayor
veamos esto en nuestra tabla de valor
posicional aquí tenemos esta tabla de
valor posicional donde podemos poner el
ejemplo anterior de 9 unidades y al
multiplicarla por 10 nuestro 9 se movió
una posición de valor hacia la izquierda
se movió a las decenas ahora tenemos 9
decenas y ponemos un 0 aquí ya que no
tenemos unidades nos quedaron 0 unidades
por lo que 9 por 10 es igual a 90
nuevamente es lo mismo que agregar un 0
al final del número pero ahora lo vemos
desde el punto de vista del valor
posicional y el multiplicar por 10 mueve
a cada dígito una posición de valor
hacia la izquierda si hacemos esto con
la misma pregunta 7 centenas si movemos
una posición de valor hacia la izquierda
tendremos millones así que 700 por 10 es
siete millares o como lo vimos
anteriormente siete mil con cualquiera
de estos métodos llegamos a la respuesta
correcta 700 por 10 es 7000 y aquí
tenemos un ejemplo con división
ahora estamos dividiendo entre 10 y se
pueden imaginar que dividir entre 10 es
lo opuesto a multiplicar por 10 por lo
que nuestros patrones también serán lo
opuesto en lugar de agregar un 0 al
final de nuestro número entero vamos a
quitar un 0 al final de este número por
ejemplo si tenemos 40 entre 10 vamos a
quitar este 0 y nos quedaremos con 4 si
dividimos 40 en grupos de 10 nos
quedarán cuatro grupos usamos esto aquí
210 decenas o dos mil 120 212 10 veces
tenemos este cero aquí y lo dividimos
entre 10 podemos usar primero este
patrón de aquí y simplemente quitar este
0 al final quitamos este 0 y nuestra
respuesta será 212 pero también podemos
usar nuestro patrón de la posición de
valor o valor posicional y en lugar de
mover una posición de valor los dígitos
hacia la izquierda
ahora vamos a mover todos los dígitos
una posición de valor a la derecha o
vamos a disminuir su valor posicional un
lugar si disminuimos en una posición
el valor posicional de 212 decenas o 212
decenas entre 10 vamos a mover las
decenas una posición de valor hacia la
derecha que nos quedará en unidades por
lo que no esta solución serán 212
unidades que es lo mismo que lo que
encontramos anteriormente simplemente
212 así que 212 decenas entre 10 podemos
escribir el número y quitarle
último cero o pensar en esto en términos
del valor posicional y mover todos los
dígitos una posición de valor a la
derecha de cualquier forma nuestra
respuesta es 212 o 212 unidades